and finally new rule Presidential
Debates need some new rules starting
with each candidate gets three times in
the debate when they can call let's go
to the videotape good idea so so that
when this happens but he also went after
a disabled reporter mocked and mimicked
him on national television she can throw
the red flag in his orange face and say
wrong tape please
I don't know what I said um I don't
remember
maybe if people could actually see from
saying one thing a second after he
claimed the opposite they'd stop
pretending there's really any other
choice in this election Rik than to vote
for Hillary Clinton okay so PolitiFact
tabulates that Hillary says something at
least somewhat false 27% of the time you
know who's at 28% Bernie the ultimate
straight shooter 27 is pretty good for a
politician Trump is at 71 his pants are
a raging wildfire that cannot be
contained she lies about a quarter of
the time he's Donald Trump so he grabs
her [ __ ] and says your [ __ ] fell on
his hand yeah does Hillary play the game
with complete honesty no to put it in
football terms
she's deflated a few balls in her time
and also that thing Tom Brady did but
she's still a really good quarterback
and speaking of quarterbacks what is a
guy like Colin Kaepernick who's brave
enough to lead a smart protest say
things like it almost seems like Hillary
and Trump are trying to debate who's
less racist you have to pick the lesser
of two evils but in the end it's still
evil really Hillary's evil you sound
like someone on Christian TV Hillary
Clinton as I was thinking about this
earlier today two names kind of came up
one was Jezebel and the other was Athol
ayah you know your Bible you know who
she was
yeah I didn't
but but I looked it up at Alya was the
daughter of Jezebel and she seized power
by murdering her grandchildren you know
just like Hillary does I'm so I am so
tired of hearing so tired of hearing I
know Trump's a creep but Hillary doesn't
seem genuine grow the [ __ ] up she's a
civil servant not a craft beer
you know whenever I'm out with my
millennial friends chasing the pokeyman
or are getting our nipples pierced
shaving our pubes or arranging action
figures while sending out dick pics when
the talk turns to the election I hear
some version of uh they're both bad or
they deserve each other or there's an
election Republicans have one path to
victory in this election and it's called
false equivalency they can't deny Trump
is horrible it's on tape so they want
voters to believe Hillary is just as bad
and in pursuit of that goal they have a
very powerful ally lazy people people
who like to say they're all bad cuz when
you say that you don't do any homework
say they're all the same and then you
can sound justifiably jaded by the
entire process when really you just
don't know anything you say you're
you say you're cynical about politics
don't flatter yourself
cynical comes when you know too much you
on the other hand haven't bothered to
learn anything which Americans by the
way are capable of Noam Chomsky once
observed that when he listens to a
sports call-in show he said it's plain
that quite a high degree of thought and
analysis is going into that people know
all sorts of complicated details on the
other hand he said when I hear people
talk about international affairs or
domestic problems it's at a level of
superficiality that's beyond belief in
other words we're not clueless we just
apply our brain power to [ __ ] it's
true before people go out for a taco
they will spend an hour on Yelp
researching for the most authentic one
all for something that will be out of
your body in 15 minutes
people will use six different websites
to get a plane ticket for a weekend trip
but they don't care who runs the world
for four years I don't get how
Millennials who can't tell these
candidates apart have a hundred
different subgenres for music that
sounds like this is that dubstep or
techno dub or acid techno cuz it all
sounds like the same [ __ ] to me
but they can tell the difference when it
comes to that